hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva this
is Brad our Lambert cousin to Colin
Farrell stand in for John ham on baby
driver and also help Jared Leto come up
with his design for the Joker he is all
three sirens someone's looking for to
get ready as you can tell by Brad STAR
Labs shirt in my Batman shirt we are
huge fans of the MCU is accidentally
wearing DC shirts for Marvel related
videos one of my favorite channels that
does list videos is what culture they're
a great channel and that's introduce
Brad to them and have a video here 10
MCU that stands for Matthew conahey
universe plot holes that aren't actually
plot holes I was a great joke don't
steal it was a fantastic joke I like
really appropriate age from the human
with a series spanning 16 movies several
one shot and countless hours a
television it would be virtually
impossible for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to get away with zero
contrivances so while the movies don't
always explain everything in perfect
detail that doesn't mean there's a gap
in logic or a continuity destroying
problem let's do our best to play
devil's advocate shall we I'm Ben from
what culture and they return MC polls
that aren't actually plot holes number
10 electricity effects Iron Man's armor
differently the Avengers when Ironman
fights Thor Thor fires a huge bolt of
lightning directly at him but instead of
this winning the battle for Thor Tony's
suit absorbs the Lightning and becomes
more powerful but in a star tear who
Tony is shown to have great difficulty
with whiplashes electric whips with his
suits of injustice to the amount of
damage and very nearly being destroyed
it sounds like a problem but it may not
be for starters two eyes always
improving areas technologies watch
discovering that his suitable weak to
this type of attack he would have
focused on making his future sad shop
come on guys number 9 rocket understands
quills Pollock joke
guardians of the galaxy in guardians of
energy Peter quill makes a joke about
the fact that his ship would look like a
Jackson Pollock painting if he's shot of
backlight around a place in responsible
correctly informs him that he has issues
with the implication being that the
raccoon understands the Pollock
reference but how could he given that he
lives and operates in space many of you
this is a glaring flaw something that
essentially breaks Rockets backstory but
it does make some sense work it never
acknowledges that he doesn't know
Jackson Pollock is and that's because he
doesn't need this information to
understand the joke hell I wasn't fully
familiar with Pollock all his work but
from context I could piece together what
star-lord was saying perhaps the bigger
question is this how does quill know the
artists work if he was abducted at the
age of eight twelve percent number eight
Toni doesn't activate the house party
protocol sooner Iron Man 3
during Iron Man 3 is climactic battle
Tony and Rhodey both agree they need a
little backup of which point dozens and
dozens of unmanned Iron Man suit fly him
to assist the pair in taking down
aldrich killian
and rescuing the president any people
questioned why Tony didn't do this
earlier in the battle
or even earlier in the film something a
lot of people missed here though is that
Tony actually activates the house party
protocol while on the speedboat with
Rhodey which is a good chunk of time
before the final battle even begins the
reason the suits appear to arrive at the
last possible second is because they
have to travel from Starks home all the
way to the shipping container yard where
the fight is happening but why not do it
even earlier well he physically couldn't
you fool earlier in the film Star
Destroyer hovering in the unmanned suit
in a thick layer of rubble they have to
dig him out first
number 7 Thor returns to earth even
though the Bifrost bridge is gone the
hearts at the end of thought the titular
god gets into an emotionally charged
scrap with his sort of the ensuing ups
resulting the Bifrost intervention ease
gateway that leads from Asgard to the
other realms being destroyed we're told
there's no way Thor will be able to
return to Earth as a result of this
situation to see him pop up on earth
with my little explanation in the
Avengers just how did he make this
journey without the Bifrost this has
been a big point of contention
it's but it's important to point out
that although the explanation offered by
the film is flimsy it's an explanation
nonetheless locally asked Thor how much
dark energy the old father had to summon
to send thought to earth G which
indicates that this was a dangerous
possibly frowned upon process or
something that only wants to do all he
wants is for Loki to be brought to
justice and so does whatever he can to
see that happen number six the Avengers
why would that mosque give away one of
the stones when his goal is to snag all
of them this is both fans figures but
there are actually several points that
together do offer a solid explanation
firstly Loki needs the assistance of the
Chitauri army in order to dominate the
earth in a deleted scene featuring
locally talking with the other thermoses
trusted follower it's implied that the
scepter gives Loki the ability to
control the Chitauri so it was necessary
that he wielded it that covers the issue
entirely but also consider what Thanos
has to gain if Loki succeeds in
obtaining the tesseract thou hast won't
just have one Infinity stone he'll have
to a risk on that mice's part the one
that he was willing to take number five
fury says there are other heroes in the
world what a gambler a man in Iron Man's
post-credits scene Nick Fury
mysteriously appears in Tony Stark's
home asking him you think you're the
only superhero in the world the
implication here is that fury knows
about the other superheroes and enhanced
individuals but how could he given that
Iron Man was the first movie in the MCU
a pub in the sort of Hulk film and there
were no references to other
super-powered beings during its runtime
how is there already an Avenger
initiative this is easily explained by
Thor dr. strange Scarlet Witch and a
whole host of other heroes didn't show
up until later there were loads of
heroes that fury and shield would have
had on my radar at the time this
post-credits scene took place Hawkeye
and black widow were already working
with fury at the time so there's two
possible candidates and she was being
monitored and we still have a brown
thumb which is set in the 90s number 4
through C Mo's plan doesn't make sense
Captain America Civil War ailments IMO's
plan in Captain America Civil War was
ridiculed by many for how outlandish
it's a plan relied on nobody knowing
what the psychiatrist said to interview
but look like ins mo was also counting
on Bucky being captured in the first
place in the movie his plan ultimately
works but isn't that incredibly silly
and incredibly unlikely maybe the movie
didn't do a perfect job of explaining
the small details of his exploits but if
you look at the plans basic outline it's
not as contrived as it appears on the
surface all Zemo does is frame Bucky for
the UN bombing in order to have him
captured which gives mo the opportunity
to interview Bucky and glean information
about the secret Hydra facility where
the tape of the stark assassination is
stored once he has that tape he's
essentially won it could release it to
the public send it to Tony in the post
or just hold on to it until the right
time
Tony's showing up at the Hydra base was
just a happy accident it's never stated
this was part of see Tony never uses it
again Iron Man 3 at the end of Iron Man
3 Pepper Potts falls to her death or so
we're made to think she actually
survived the fall thanks to the extremis
virus the technology that can heal
people make them stronger and even
regrow limbs Tony removes the virus from
pepper in order to make her normal again
and it hasn't been seen in an MCU movie
since but if Tony was familiar with this
technology and could use it for good why
does he just leave it alone couldn't
extremis be used to help out Rhodey
after his injury and Captain America's
Civil War they like a logical choice but
bear in mind extremis is also capable of
blowing people up and that seems like a
big enough factor number 2 Tony is Iron
Man again despite retiring Avengers age
of Ultron hey you know Tony gives a
speech about not needing his Iron Man
armor and how it was just a cocoon
Tony's line and now I'm a changed man
made it seem like he was moving on from
his Iron Man days and focusing on
helping the world as Tony Stark and not
as a vigilante hero and then Avengers
age of Ultron happened and Tony was back
in the soup so what happened well
there's another line in his speech I am
Iron Man and while that could be taken
to mean Tony views himself as a hero
whether he wears a suit or not it could
also be taken
he is an outright abandoning pursuits
his decision to remove the shrapnel and
arc reactor is him burying the demons of
his past halting that over reliance on
his armor the plating throughout Iron
Man 3
age of Ultron does continue this story
threat Tony is working on Ultron a
global peacekeeping program that would
remove the need for Heroes and while
this plan goes wrong the intent is still
there
number one banner suddenly learns to
control his Hulk powers this problem
using more done time and time again
since the Avengers first opened but the
moment in which Bruce Banner transforms
into the Hulk an takes damage to Terry
while in full control of his actions is
perfectly in keeping with everything we
already know about the character Bruce
didn't suddenly develop this power right
when it became useful in fact he can
already control his health
transformations at the beginning of the
movie right at the start of the film
Bruce angrily lashes out a black widow
just so he can see her reaction would he
deliberately make himself angry if he
knew there was a chance the Hulk could
be unleashed of course not because he
can already control his powers then
flash forward to the time bomb argument
see here Bruce literally says he will
show the other Avengers that he can
transform at will but is interrupted by
the beeping computer the reason why Hulk
turned aggressive on the Helicarrier is
because he was being manipulated by Loki
and the mind stone and Hawk eyes
explosion caught him off guard he only
loses control due to the unprecedented
nature of the circumstances one of the
minions ever he's in full control of his
abilities and that's our list make sure
you subscribe to the WOD coaching
YouTube channel list visit what culture
comedy please subscribe to these guys
please subscribe to these guys alright
let's go through this list a little bit
Brad but I loved of how they composed
this list and every time they brought up
the thing and they said why it sounds
illogical I always went that's true
I'm gonna explain I go I get it man I
should think about more things sometimes
or I just jump to the conclusion that
it's a flaw you call that pretty quick
you're like as before as before avengers
so you must have developed a technology
to be able to work with it cuz that's
the way Tony operates yeah he's always
looking to make the suits better so in
Iron Man 2 when he fought whiplash and
got his ass kicked
Avengers obviously took place after yeah
man 2 which makes sense that
two would be more equipped to handle
something like that what about rocket
understanding quills poly choke I still
don't quite get it as I feel like the
way Chris Pratt says the line I don't
know who Jason Pollak was I still don't
I like even hearing that now I'm like I
think the context was in the backlight
comment what's revealed with a backlight
I think people are too focused on the
pollak aspect of that because we all
know once you put a black light on
something what's going to be seen in
that kind of context so yeah I think
that's why rocket understood it people
who don't know who Pollock is yeah fine
in that context when he's talking about
his adventures with women so it's not so
much Pollock part of this they're
talking about white stuff yeah something
I've never been able to produce myself
jeesus it's really sad I get tested
moving on there right because that makes
you question more of how did a 10 year
old boy know who Jason Pollock is I'm a
27 year old man and I have no idea
Tony doesn't activate the house party
protocol sooner I mean even though they
explain it here you know like how it
gets buried in everything what did you
think the suits can break through all
the destruction that was going on then
again they do show that this suits
easily fall apart yeah okay okay it's
not a plot hole he essentially was
waiting for the way to clean off because
they don't really use the suits for its
strength purposes now they're more for
like the energy blasts and all that
stuff yeah yeah yeah they work better in
a quantity but in terms of straight they
kind of do fall apart pretty easily
correct okay okay Marvel you got a
creative team thinking about these
things
okay you got to explain to me how how
Thor was able to come to earth because I
even when they were explaining I'm like
wait I still don't understand
obviously the Bifrost was destroyed in
your movie so that was his usual way of
moving all around the galaxy yes when I
was destroyed he said he'd never be able
to go to earth again well but Odin his
father the or father he obviously has
the ability to manipulate dark matter
which is dangerous as Loki said he was
able to conjure up enough dark matter to
transport Thor back to earth it was a
obviously a desperate scenario
how'd she pick up on all that because
Loki said it in the Avengers film up on
the cliff he's like how much dark manner
did the or father have to conjure you
here are you some seventh nerd demos
plan doesn't make sense when I watched
Civil War I think it's a little bit
ridiculous at the same time though I
feel like Zemo is kind of improvising
through a lot of the movie yeah he has
to I mean that's what happens with plans
the smart man knows plans don't always
go according to plan so you got to
constantly readjust I don't know how
he's able to get in there as a
psychiatrist though that's what I can't
figure well he he killed the
psychiatrist he was supposed to
interview Bucky
when did they establish that when Tony's
in the chopper and he gets the message
on his phone that shows the psychiatrist
murdered in his bathtub the woman finds
him you know I can't pay attention to
everything Brad there's so much going on
to that damn movie yeah but but but
here's the main his goal was to tear
apart the Avengers if he got that tape
to show Tony to split cap and Tony apart
that was the angle and when like they
broke it down in the video it wasn't an
accident he was either gonna release it
to the media or whatever but it just so
happened that Tony and cap showed up at
the facility so he just showed it to him
there it was easy but that video
obviously is what separated cap and Tony
because cap knew the whole time that
Bucky killed his parents you know what I
don't like about these Marvel movies
they expect me to be like a smart
audience member yeah expect me to pay
attention to like everything and pick up
on little things that are clearly laid
out in the dialogue you can't respect
your audience that much I'm just saying
I'm just saying I feel like we kind of
learned about banner because I hurt have
heard that complaint yeah inside of
Avengers when he you know I'm always
angry and then he smashes it I thought
in the Incredible Hulk movie they show
that he's around he it's there he
figures out how to channel his power
correct if they're when he fights
abomination yes but it's more towards
the end of the film when he's sitting
there I think
doing yoga and he's sitting there and he
opens his eyes and I shot a film and
it's green no yeah I mean that makes it
very clear that he's learning how to
control his anger and learning when to
activate it when he fights abomination
he has a clear goal yeah take down
abomination and he's able to go through
with that goal yeah
and in the end he doesn't even kill him
when he has the chance to I don't really
like The Incredible Hulk movie as a
whole but I really did like that last
half-hour I thought the fan is really
well done I agree I always thought that
was a complaint that can be definitely
disputed they show that he's working on
channeling and controlling it because he
knows he can't get rid of it
they're mean to work with it and I felt
like being kind of a hoax set that up
pretty damn well actually and when he's
pushed out a helicopter banner says in
the Avengers that he tries to kill
himself by shooting himself in the head
yeah in his mouth he says the other guy
spit it out so he can't even yeah like
you can't be there's no choice what's
worked out when he's pushed out of the
chopper I mean the Hulk's going to
essentially save him right I'm excited
though thor ragnarok he's been Hulk for
a while now yeah we've seen in pieces
where he's speaking now so he's kind of
yeah thats I'm interested to see how
they balance that with like a Hulk
format for a lot of the movie and
actually talking yeah it's gonna be fun
alright well thanks for culture for
helping me understand these major plot
holes that have completely ruined the
MCU for me up until now thank you yes
cuz up until then I hated all MCU films
and now I understand them they are
brilliantly done subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
Brad are Lambert clearly doesn't pay
attention in movies as well as I do but
hey do him a favor follow this producer
slash photographer friend of mine on
Instagram producers are supposed to pay
attention to the little things Brad you
go okay you can learn a thing or two
from this guy you can learn a thing or
two I take care